oh we talk we talked about we talk about
joe rogan too much we we certainly do
and i've acknowledged that before and i
guess the issue is
you know we're sitting down and we're
looking at all the news today we got the
story spotify to take down neil young's
music after his joe rogan ultimatum and
i'm sitting here and you know and i look
over at our good friend tom and i'm like
what's more important stephen breyer a
supreme court justice retiring or neil
young losing his battle with spotify to
get joe rogan banned and i i don't know
because i feel like the supreme court is
more important but you made a really
great point you said the the great
suppression is is the biggest story or
something that affects yeah well that's
what we're in the midst of the great
suppression we have massive censorship
uh or an effort for censorship targeting
opposition to
whatever you want to call it the big
state deep state
the communists whoever you want to call
it
and the communists are willing to use
multi-millionaires like
uh
neil young to suppress
other successful people like
but he lost yeah he lost and you know
but it's but rogan isn't the only one
being targeted it's his listeners being
targeted so when you take away a leading
voice that people look up to
and communicate and use as a basis for
further communications that's
suppression of all of rogan's audience
so whenever we're suppressed
all of our followers are suppressed and
harmed as well
it's the great suppression and it's not
private it's government it's private and
uh and it's corporate
so we have a quote here i guess this is
from uh this is from spotify they say
mr young's record label warner music uh
warner group corpse warner records
formally requested spotify remove his
music wednesday which would take several
hours to take effect across spotify
services across the world quote we want
all the world's music and audio content
to be available to spotify users with
that comes great responsibility in
balancing both safety for listeners and
freedom for creators spotify spokesman
said wednesday
we regret neil's decision to remove his
music from spotify but hope to welcome
him back soon now
the way the left is portraying this is
neil young stood for on his principles
and said i do not want to share a
platform with that man and so they took
his music down i see it as a big loss
because what his intent what he was
trying to do was he was like i'm neil
young yep you better ban joe rogan or
i'm out and they were like dude joe
rogan gets hundreds of millions of of
downloads per month and you get six
yeah you don't have any new music that's
like breaking the charts dude you're not
nicki minaj well that's the thing it's
that really embarrassing outdated
rockstar ego like this isn't a
convention center where you can request
you only have green m ms in the bowl or
you or you throw a fit like joe rogan
gets way more views and downloads than
him and i don't know why neil young
thought himself in a position to
determine what we should be able to
listen to but i think it's kind of
hilarious that spotify gave him the old
okay boomer get off our platform we
don't care we don't need you is he a
boomer though he's 76 oh my gosh he's
older than one well i apologize i
apologize for miss generationing uh
you're young but i'm telling you i'm
glad i'm glad his music's off no point
because i think it's great but is that
boomer or is that silent uh it's like
1944.
yeah okay so i was right tim boomer i
was like 44 right 1944 is when they
began and it was silent up until then
i'm generation x
yeah that's handled
and boomer is ahead of that well point
is i think it's a fantastic victory the
fact that this old school celebrity who
thinks he's a lot cooler and more
relevant than he is tried to throw his
weight around and got taken down is uh
kind of incredible but he's the oldest
you can be to be a boomer i just googled
it says 76 68 to 76
and then technically it says you could
also be 58 to 7 to 67. there's like two
boomer generations i guess okay no no no
no that's silent generation the world's
oldest boomer he's got boobs
on spotify i'm about it ian
good i you know i think of neil young
he's always struck me as an angry dude
when i was a kid i used to look at his
face and be like why is he silent
generation i was right sheamus was wrong
well you were the silent generation when
the mic wasn't working earlier
big talk sheamus yeah so um
but this is this is uh uh i mean this is
a big story it's it's
what i got out of this and i mentioned
this the other day is neil young this
protest guy i thought he was supposed to
be protesting free speech right well
anti-war is his big thing i don't think
he's a free speech guy no the anti-war
movement was the free speech movement he
was part of that yeah
and now they're like oh speech is bad
how many warhawks has neil young tried
to protest being on the same platform as
he he
did the story attacking mt he did the
song attacking mtv
for taking commercials or you know being
too corporate and he complained that the
mtv wouldn't play his song
so the irony of him trying to suppress
another you know artist
or sp another uh another person who has
a right a god-given right to share his
views
and you know this is a battle you know
it's embarrassing i think for the left
here but they don't they're never
embarrassed they don't stop because
normal people would be embarrassed
they're not they don't follow those
rules they they had the scientists who
weren't scientists try to
pressure to take him off they were
hoping to get a a ball rolling with with
neil young and something else they'll
keep on pushing rogue rogan is a threat
and they're not going to stop but that's
i i don't i don't think zombies get get
embarrassed that they're eating brains
you know what i mean yeah yeah exactly
going and they just well isn't it
hilarious that they put together this
list of like 300 doctors who weren't
really doctors dentists yeah dentists
and they thought like that didn't work
so they're like we're busting out the
big guys we're gonna get nealy young to
try to take him now you're saying they
you think that people were encouraging
neil to do this yeah yeah the organized
left has they've been doing this for
years uh in terms of targeting um voices
they disagree with and
usually it's uh trying to
controversialize them to get commercials
off or advertisers off you know rush
limbaugh was
faced this years ago so it's you know
unfortunately there's nothing new under
the sun but it's gotten worse things
have metastasized in terms of
of the attack on speech and it's and
it's
you know i in my view is we're in a
revolutionary moment it's dangerous i
agree i agree but i will say following
this story uh i hope neil young will
remember that freedom loving people
don't need them around anyhow love it
yeah beautiful i got to tell you i i've
lived in georgia for the past couple
years and it's true a southern man don't
need him around anyhow i mean he
apologized for that apparently you know
when he got criticized for right neil
young wrote these two songs criticizing
the south and then he actually
commented on it later being like yeah i
shouldn't have written those songs they
were they were too broad cancel culture
i wanna i wanna say real quick the
funniest thing about this story
is how the one person who's not talked
about it is joe rogan himself
like he doesn't care
it doesn't involve him he's minding his
own business and everyone else is like
where you know we're sitting here waving
our arms in there hooting and hollering
like oh and it's like i i just i imagine
it's just joe's like i i have a feeling
i call him and be like hey this neil
young thing it'll be like what happened
yeah i'm like neil young they try to get
you banned and he'd be like
i don't know what you're talking about
i'd be like oh well he doesn't care yeah
the public policy implication the
problem is you've got the media
celebrating it though yeah you know neil
young it's ridiculous as we're talking
about but the media kind of salivating
and celebrating the targeting of young
and you see
uh you know the cnn types and people
like that they they love that this is
happening
and so that's the dangerous side of it
you've got this whole media
political complex
uh along with big tech
uh that is excited about taking out
voices they don't like
well their ratings are in the gutter
their revenues are in the gutter yeah i
think i think we saw that turning point
for cnn when they lost their airport
contracts and all of a sudden i mean
that was what 95 of their viewership
yeah and i'm only half kidding to be
honest i don't think it was that much
right cnn's viewership was largely
airports and hotel lobbies yeah and then
they lost the airport deal that could be
a big reason why their ratings tanked
and just just you know but i don't know
if they actually count the airport stuff
in the ratings to be honest people are
probably gonna be like no they don't do
that but they lost tremendous reach yeah
yeah they know they're losing it to joe
rogan among other people they're
competitive and you know the dishonest
side of it is their competitors well
it's not even just politics it's a
business the businesses they're losing
viewers to people like rogan
and and you and frankly anyone else who
has a voice online that
normally isn't heard in cnn well and
that's what's so hilarious about the
entire situation you're absolutely right
people are looking at this as a matter
of politics and on some level it is but
what is very interesting is the fact
that he is direct competition for them
in the business that they're operating
in and so when they write these articles
about him it's literally people who work
for the companies that he's competing
with talking about how horrible he is
well of course they're going to say that
and what the media always does and what
the left always does is as soon as they
start losing they immediately portray
themselves as martyrs and victims but
the narrative falls apart with rogan
because he's one guy who people really
want to listen to and they make it seem
like he's this reckless and
irresponsible man who's bullying them
hey but isn't it crazy how they've
really ramped up the attacks on joe
rogan yeah
i was just reading a story like some
some attorney general was saying joe
rogan should be censored who was that
lady he's like they're trump now yeah
some some attorney general was like
biden's attorney general he thinks it
was biden's yeah wow should be sensitive
the surgeon general came out and said
something about disinformation online i
don't know if he said specifically about
rogue yeah not the attorney general no
surgeon general yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time